as the river Taff throws the danger was
clear but homes were defenseless as the
water poured in all the documents for
the house sniffing are all gone and in
the aftermath it's a feeling of
helplessness Carrie is one of many
people in Ponte breathe without flood
insurance he's trying to sell this house
to move into his new one up the street
both are flooded kind of 1,000 pound to
flood insurance there's a lot of people
on this street who haven't got it done
I've always had insurance up until this
year because I'm in the process of
moving they were come to take
photographs yesterday morning of it just
need to go online on Monday but no it's
not gonna happen we wasn't buying this
house now South Wales felt the full
impact of storm Dennis the most severe
rain warning since 2015 was issued here
but the most resources were sent
elsewhere the leader of plight camry is
calling for an urgent review of flooding
policy do you think Wales has been
neglected when it comes to flood
preparation I certainly think that the
Welsh government I mean has been under
investing and they're investing in flood
defense and mitigation policy over many
many years and it's gonna get worse
so now you know if we needed another
wake-up call then this is it and in
price is also calling for a uk-wide
disaster fund to help those hit by
flooding the issue of insurance is a big
problem here Wales is one of the poorest
countries in Europe the valleys one of
its poorest areas there are so many
people here who simply don't have the
money to pay for flood insurance and
they now have no idea how to recover
from losing everything local donations
are pouring in but it can only do so
much Natural Resources Wales says it's
the poverty level here that also hinders
their demand for more money for flood
defences but some say they should have
called on the Army for extra help we
didn't call the military because we
can't predict with enough time to get
equipment and things in and on our
rivers a lot of these rivers
natural rivers it would be almost
impossible to prevent flooding in these
localities you just be pushing flooding
problems elsewhere these communities
have been hard hit but they look after
each other rescue the dogs yeah but one
of them safe themselves the Labrador got
managed to swim upstairs but the other
one didn't make it for now recovery is
the priority but people here also want
reassurance they'll be better protected
in the future
Sallie Lockwood Sky News now Gary in
South Wales